hello everyone uh we are starting in few
seconds uh so uh meanwhile while we're
starting off today's uh session is about
basically UI of X and we'll be talking
about what it takes to build a uifx
career in 2023 uh and we already have a
speaker with us Professor Preeti uh so
what we can do is meanwhile we have 10
more minutes to start this Edition folks
who have joined in early that's great I
would love to know where your folks are
joining from
so I'll just type in here like I am
joining from Bangalore India I would
love to know where you folks is running
from on chat here so my name is Russia
I'm your host today
and uh
where are you joining from
I would want to know on chart here
meanwhile let's interact let's get to
know each other better right it's a good
place to network right these webinars
I can see folks are responding in
already
okay I can see
Narendra has said good evening good
evening
I can see abhi has said from Andhra
Pradesh Ashok has joined from Dubai hey
hi folks so uh we're starting the
session in uh exact eight minutes you
folks have joined in early so what we
can do is we can just introduce
ourselves on chat here uh and network a
little bit
yeah I can see folks are responding on
chat they've started talking that's nice
okay we have someone from Italy as well
hey I mean we can see ship is
foreign
X and also today's topic and the
advanced certification by triple IIT
Bangalore in UI WX uh so what you can do
is there's a q a box uh you can see if
you're joined from your mobile or laptop
you can put down your questions there
and uh we'll be taking those questions
towards the end of the session or in
between as well you know so we'll be
taking all the questions you will get
answer to you all your queries
so meanwhile I can see folks are already
introducing themselves on chat
they're joining from different different
parts of India and also you know from
different different uh parts of the
world as well that's good to know we
have gotten a diverse set of audience
here
yeah we'll start in uh eight minutes
because we have just started this
session a little earlier so you guys can
talk with each other on chat here
uh gaurav has asked the question is
there any certificate for joining the
webinar yes there is you will be getting
a certificate post webinar uh for
joining this session so yeah stay as
long as you can I would suggest for the
certificate as well so yeah
I hope that answers your question
meanwhile our folks who are just joining
in now uh will be starting in five
minutes you folks have joined in early
that is great so settle down wherever
you are if you're joining mobile laptop
meanwhile uh just to let you know uh
that you can just raise your questions
in the Q a box we'll be taking it
throughout the session and mostly
towards the end of it so uh all your
queries will be answered related to uvx
and we already have a speaker with us
Professor Preeti so uh she will be
helping you uh through the session to
understand the advanced certification in
uh UI wix
yes there is a webinar certificate folks
if you can hear me you will be getting
uh that post webinar
uh you'll be receiving it over meal
gaurav
okay meanwhile uh folks who are joining
in now uh just to let you know we're
just talking on chat here we're just
introducing ourselves so uh I'm your
host
here Russia and I'll just introduce uh
myself on channel here so I'm joining
you from Bangalore
from
meanwhile we start let's Network a bit
right on chart I can see folks have
already started introducing themselves
you're welcome
okay I can see Umar has joined from
Nigeria
and uh I can see few details about the
programmer also going on already like
kalyani is actually briefing about the
program helping out the crowd that's
amazing I can see popender has joined
from Orissa Anna has joined from
Telangana I can see gaurav has joined
from West Bengal
welcome everyone
so
yes uh the webinar certificate uh I'm
not sure like it would be useful for
getting jobs but you can definitely add
it to your resume right there's always a
it's always a good thing right like
adding uh certificates to resume of
relevant things in case you're applying
for uav's job I would suggest to uh add
it to your profile why not give it a try
I can see omkar has joined from Mumbai
so welcome everyone
will be starting in few minutes you
folks have joined in early you can see a
lot of folks are still joining it so
meanwhile what we can do is we can just
introduce ourselves on chat here and uh
I'll just introduce myself again for new
folks who have joined in so I'm Russia
I'll be your host uh for today's webinar
and I'm joining from Bangalore India I
would love to know where you are joining
from
okay I can see Shashank is joined from
hi
you can put down your questions in the Q
a box I'll be just putting that in the
chat here as well
because we get a lot of messages on chat
here and we don't want to miss out uh
your query your question you know so we
would love to help you with that but as
per the flow of the session we'll be
taking those questions so don't worry
about that
we'll be starting in few minutes
meanwhile I can see folks are still
introducing themselves over Charter good
way to network right so utilize this
time before we start I would say and uh
we've got in a very interactive audience
here today so that's really good
foreign
so yeah uh before we start just to let
you know that if you have any question
uh if you put it on chat here I might
miss out on that and I would love for
your question to get answered by
Professor PT here anything related to
uifx Career so what you can do is you
can start putting down your questions on
the Q a box this is a good time I'm
pretty sure you already have a question
I I I we actually have started getting
questions already so that's great uh so
we'll be taking this questions
throughout the session and also there
will be a special uh you know uh time
towards the end of session to take those
q a questions as well in case we have
missed out on uh the questions here so
yeah I can see people are still
introducing them just so I'm just typing
uh this on chat here just in case you
have missed it that you can put down
your questions on uh q a box here please
make it related to UI X because the
session is about your FX so we can help
you with that today and also uh you can
introduce yourself on chat here we'll be
starting the session in just few minutes
so yeah
I can see someone is asking question on
chat I'm so sorry we might miss it so
please put it down in the Q a folks are
already putting the questions in the Q a
box here if you join from your mobile or
laptop it will help you uh you know go
and put down those questions there
instead of chat so we might miss it as
we're getting a lot of questions here uh
on chat and people are introducing them
chat here I can see Kofi has joined from
Africa Ghana
okay
and uh Jagdish put down your questions
on the Q a box
I will miss those questions because of
the chat room that will be very helpful
yeah
I can see folks are joining from Tamil
Nadu Bangalore Hyderabad Pune so we have
folks from different different
parts of the world and India as well a
lot of folks from India I understand
uh so yeah so uh today's session is
about UI works and advanced
certification in UI Works through triple
it Bangalore and today we are going to
talk about what it takes to build a UI
wax career in 2018 and also we'll be
sharing the ultimate your WebEx career
Kickstarter so uh we already have
Professor preethi here with us Professor
Petey thank you for joining us I would
love to know where are you joining us
from while before introducing themselves
would love to know where you are also
joining from well I'm joining from
Bangalore I'm a professor at triple it
Bangalore so this is a city where you
I'm talking to you know awesome awesome
I can see a lot of Bangalore folks also
joining uh and Mumbai Tamil Nadu I can
see Bihar as well
we have gotten a very engaging audience
today so really good audience
I can feel the energy from the audience
here so we'll just wait for few more
minutes meanwhile we what we can do is
we can just start
so uh while folks are still joining in
so maybe we can just go through the
agenda so today's agenda is about UAV
Design Careers we'll be talking more
about that and what this program exactly
offers the advanced certification in UI
Wix through triple it Bangalore and also
uh how this program gets your job ready
I think few of the folks had a question
about this so I would suggest to go and
put it in the Q a box it will be helpful
for us to take those questions and
answer it and also we'll be taking you
through the enrollment steps and uh
obviously there will be a special uh
session for the Q ready as well
so yeah you'll be starting in some time
we'll just give it few more minutes
because folks are still joining in
awesome they're introducing them this is
all chat that's amazing uh so just to
let you know folks who have this joint
right now uh just a ground rule that you
would need to put down your questions in
the Q a box uh q a box is not the
webinar chat webinar chat is where
basically where we interact to any box
if you can see on your screen right now
you can just go and put down your
questions there and I'll make sure we
take those questions
so folks who have just joined right now
also we have gotten folks from Nigeria
as well Andhra Pradesh joining in I can
see Renu has joined from Hyderabad
bhavna has joined from Delhi
awesome welcome everyone so we're
starting the session so I am Russia your
host today and we'll be talking about
the UI ux certification uh from triple
it Bangles
uh so I would like to welcome Professor
Preeti uh for joining us in uh who will
be taking us to the triple it
bangalore's Advanced certification in UI
ux uh Professor Piti would you like to
give us your introduction
sure so good evening everyone and thanks
for joining I'm excited to be speaking
to all of you on what you can expect as
part of this certification so as you can
see on the slide I'm a professor at
triple it Bangalore and I teach courses
in qualitative research methods uh human
computer interaction which is the
academic domain from which uh
um uh Notions of user interface user
experience come from so I teach courses
both in human computer interaction as
well as advanced human computer
interaction and
um since I'm an academic I uh my bread
and butter comes from teaching as well
as from publishing so a lot of the
scholarship that I produce
involves access studying people's access
to technology especially in the context
of gender Dynamics
my most recent research interests are
around infrastructures biometric
infrastructures gig economy platforms
and new use processes and I mainly
publish in the domains of ictd and HCI
4D this stands for information and
communication Technologies for
development as well as human computer
interaction for development
um my academic Journey involves a
bachelor's degree in Commerce believe it
or not post which I studied
communication studies for my masters at
the University of Pune I worked as a
journalist with the Indian Express for a
couple of years after that before
returning back to Academia I got my PhD
in communication studies from the
University of Texas at Austin and the
methods that I use in my own work are
generally qualitative and ethnographic
methods which means that I spend a lot
of my time not in my office on campus
but Outdoors interacting with people
conducting interviews doing observations
just trying to understand
um their relationship and processes of
interacting technology so that is a
little bit about me I'm happy to answer
more questions about my background and
about my work please leave your
questions in the Q a box and we'll take
it to RCN so uh thank you so much uh
Professor Preeti for your introduction
uh yes as professori said like if you
have any questions related to the
experience part as well you know her
experience how basically you know you're
dealing with your career here and uh
what point you know what all things you
did in case anything related to the
experience as well please feel free to
ask because that's a really good
inspiration to take you know so uh let's
move on uh so we'll be starting about
the careers in UI WX design
uh Professor Preeti uh so how does UI ux
design shapes how we interact with our
world can you tell us more about that
right so um uh UI stands for user
interface and ux stands for user
experience and both of these domains are
not mutually exclusive they come
together uh they intersect uh to really
Center the user in the entire design
process and help us create products that
are both functional which means that uh
which people find easy and intuitive to
use as well as aesthetically pleasing so
they should also take pleasure in using
that particular product and it is not
just about
functionality and this is important
because only if people enjoy using your
products and services will you have user
satisfaction will they remain loyal to
your business and it will give you a
Competitive Edge over the other players
in the market who are obviously you're
not going to all be the only player in
the market so um uh essentially what
this means is that you have to put users
first you really have to Center people
and understand what are their needs and
how is it that they are using technology
and what is their pain points so we take
a very customer-centric approach uh in
these in in within the ux UI domain
because
um it is only that that is going to help
us build a very strong brand perception
for the Production Services that we are
working on and the aim really is to make
it easy and when I say make it easy it
essentially means that your users
shouldn't have to spend a very long time
trying to figure out and learn how do I
use this particular product they should
not have a lot of friction when they
first encounter your product or service
to figure out okay uh what should I be
doing next what kind of
um uh challenges am I facing so it's
really the job of the ux researcher the
ux designer the UI designer to come
together to identify what are the pain
points of these users where are they
encountering friction what can we do to
reduce friction how can we improve user
engagement with our products
um how can we improve customer
satisfaction
um what are the pain points where you
know our users seem to be very confused
about what steps to take next and what
can we do to reduce this confusion to
eliminate this kind of confusion
um when you're engaged as a professional
in answering these kinds of questions
um why do why do organizations hire
Professionals in the ux UI domain
because
um like I mentioned it helps to build a
strong brand perception it improves
Customer Loyalty all of this really
results in long-term cost saving
um for the company and it improves
Customer Loyalty customer retention
which is very important for any
organization so as professionals we uh
when we align with the UI ux domain we
are essentially focused on making
interactions very pleasant and easy for
the customer due to all of these various
points
uh that's great
I can see one question coming on chat
here which is a very interesting
question I want to say so uh I think
shivaram has asked like ma'am what
motivated you to be in this UI which
designing industry compared to today's
AI Technologies how can we tackle with
AI
um
I'm not able to see this question but uh
um what motivated me to be in this
industry if you're asking in comparison
uh to AI at the time that I entered this
particular domain
um uh generative AI in the in the form
that we know it today was not really
around and I I do see another question
asking can AI replace the work of UI ux
um I think generative AI in the form
that we know it today is not really uh
you know it's not at a stage where it is
replacing
um a certain job roles
um in every profession the role that
generative AI especially is playing
today is that it helps complement things
with UI ux
um because a lot of the kind of work
that we do involves direct interaction
with users
um AI is not going to really help you
replace that where it can help you is
like for instance now you have spoken to
say 30 customers right 30 of your users
of your products and you have received
you have answers to interviews you have
answers to survey questions you have
taken down on observations because
you've observed your users how are they
using what are the pain points so say
you have 10 pages of notes right so um
how AI can help you work better as a UI
design professional is maybe you feed
um all of your insights that you have
received that
take the help of your AI tool
um to help you make patterns from the
responses that you have received in a
sense data analysis so it could probably
help you
analyze data better but I don't really
uh Envision
um AI replacing the role of UI ux also
because see a good UI ux design
professional
um brings things like empathy to the
design process now
um an AI tool cannot really generate
empathy it's not good at doing these
kinds of things right it's not good at
dealing with emotions so therefore it's
going to be very difficult for AI to
replace the UI ux design professional
you can use an AI tool to help you work
better but I don't Envision
um a scenario where it is going to
completely eliminate or replace a design
professional I hope that answers your
question
yeah uh yeah thank you so much Professor
uh I I hope that answers your question I
think that question was by Narendra if
I'm current right
from the Q a box okay yes so I think we
already are talking about what a UI ux
designer does uh so can you take us
through uh what exactly goes on uh
basically while working as a ux designer
yes so like I said your primary job uh
really comes from interacting with your
users and
um how do you begin interacting with
your users you can do it in various ways
for instance if uh if you're working on
a fairly mature uh product or service
you will have access to backend data
that will help you understand it will it
will reveal user metrics to you and you
will be able to understand who your
target user group is uh based both on
backend data as well as you know who is
it that your organization or firm is
interested in targeting so
um what does your organization identify
as a Target user group and then once you
identify who your user groups are you
will spend a lot of time talking to them
and observing how is it that they are
interacting
um with the product or not even just
looking at interaction with the product
just trying to understand
um what are the needs right what are the
needs and the pain points and um you so
this is typically what we call as field
work so you take these insights from the
field work and
the process of UI ux gives us various
tools uh how do we how do we approach
these insights how do we convert these
insights into concrete deliverables so
for instance one uh uh technique that
design professionals uses that you take
insights from speaking to your target
users and you create personas and
personas are representations of who your
users are and you give them certain
characteristics because
um you most likely may not be the target
user for the product or the service that
you're working on so you need to
understand
um who the target user is and converting
your insights into Persona is often a
good way to do that
um and through this process we use
several methods that are very particular
to the UI uh design process so as you
can see on the slide
um you you will be using techniques such
as you know how do I build the user flow
diagram what is useful diagram mean what
what are the input output methods that
what are the input methods that the
users are going to be
putting into the system to execute
certain tasks what is the output going
to look like how is it going to change
the state of the system what what kind
of feedback are you providing to the
user to let them know that yes your
input has been received and this is how
the system is responding
um we use techniques such as
storyboarding the entire user flow
process we build scenarios
we build user stories we do information
architecture to understand what is the
site navigation for a particular product
or service is going to look like
um and
um we then also engage in testing so
whatever we build we you will be
interacting with developers to help it
bring to reality and then you also need
to test right so this is these are the
changes that I have made or this is how
I have envisioned in the design process
now is it making sense so you go back to
your user and you give them certain
scenarios and you ask them to walk you
through
um how they are going to be using this
product and service and there are
several tests that we then conduct to
understand what kind of pain points are
the users again encountering has the
problem being resolved
um as a good design professional you
have to also constantly keep an eye out
for what your competitors are doing and
how their design is evolving Because
unless you understand your competitor
you are not going to be able to give
that edge to bring that edge to your own
product so you have to have a very keen
eye on
um you know how are your competitors or
what is the general design discourse for
your product or service
um in in a particular scenario because
this is a very Dynamic kind of fast
changing landscape right we don't
encounter the static landing pages and
features are constantly evolving and
changing right so um just maintain a
bird's eye view of what's happening in
your landscape
um you can expect to like I said
um uh be involved in testing certain
user interface elements now user
interface is mainly to do with the
visual look and feel of the website and
that would include things like call to
action buttons uh how does the
information architecture of your uh of
your layout look like what kind of links
are you
um inputting onto your page where will
these links take users when they click
on it how are you going to design
landing pages Thanos even notifications
so ux writing uh you know what kind of
text Will your users be reading is also
very important because so much of
especially
um the kind of apps that we use they
rely a lot on push notifications for you
so how should these notifications
locations be designed what kind of text
and how will they be written and then of
course you understand you spend time
then understanding and refining the
specifications of the product or service
and
um you know go deeper into understanding
the psychology of your users just get to
know them in a much better manner so
that you can customize your design
interventions to better serve their
needs
uh I hope that answers your question uh
a lot of folks are asking about the
roadmap I guess you'll be taking that in
some time uh so yeah please don't worry
about that uh so also uh like what is
the sample job description like a UI of
X aspirin can look for you know uh can
you tell us more about that so uh here
on the screen is a typical uh sample job
description I'll I'll read this through
for you and I will pause to explain that
I feel explanations are necessary and
then feel free to answer me questions
particular to this uh job description so
for instance um uh a lot of you may be
active on LinkedIn and you may be coming
across a lot of hiring notices for
design professionals typically what is
it going to say it will tell you that
you will be working with both design
team and developmental team now
development teams are generally the
engineers who are going to be bringing
your ideas to life through programming
and code right so you will be working
with the as a design professional you
will be working with the design 19 but
they are not the only people you will be
working with and teamwork becomes very
important which means that you also need
to have good communication skills
because collaboration is going to be the
heart of what you're going to be doing
so um you will be working with design
team and development teams to produce
engaging intuitive and enjoyable user
experiences for end users and I've
already explained the importance of all
of this as ux designers you participate
in product Discovery design and delivery
so you will both be discovering uh needs
user needs then you will take those
discoveries and convert them into
concrete
design interventions for your product or
service and then you will work with the
development team to ensure that this is
delivered to the users you work closely
with a client to understand their
business needs and with end users to
understanding the goals right so you
have to interface both with the business
side of your product and also the user
side so you will in fact be bridging
both of these ends and you can also
expect to work closely with product
owners so these are generally product
managers in the corporate parlance to
help you develop a product Vision right
so they are essentially going to
um be telling you because they will be
representing the business side of things
so um uh they will be telling you what
is the vision for this product and um
how can we best execute this to server
users
um you craft product Solutions and
present to the design team the
development team end users and
stakeholders to collect feedback and
iterate towards the best solution and
this is the reason why AI is not going
to be replacing this but it will
complement and help you work better you
establish patterns and create familiar
experiences that reduce the end user's
cognitive load and you directly impact
the lives of those on your team our
client and most definitely end users so
what are the requirements to be able to
execute this particular job description
so you should have experience in
research and data to guide
recommendations this means you should
know how to conduct research and how to
collect data because that is really the
core the Beating Heart of water design
professional does
um then you should also have
experiencing prototyping and uh
presenting design Solutions now
prototyping means that
um before you make the final design
intervention for your users you first
make mock-ups right your first
do it on a smaller scale uh do it or
sketch it on paper or you build
cardboard prototypes um so that you know
your you are able to identify problems
early and um it also results in lesser
cost for the company so you need to have
experience and you need to know how is
it that we prototype these design
Solutions
um you should also have experience in
human centered design now human centered
design means centering the user keeping
people at the core of all
um solutions that you're designing
because eventually you have to serve the
needs of the users right so it is not
designing from say the business point of
view but keeping people at the core of
everything that you do you should also
be familiar with industry standard tools
such as figma sketch Adobe XP figma is
really the tool that is currently
um uh the industry favorite so you have
to be very familiar and you should know
how to use Sigma you should have
familiarity with front-end technology
although this is not you needn't
necessarily be an expert but it helps
right so you should know basics of HTML
CSS JavaScript and eventually to be able
to get your foot into the door for a
design job opportunity it is very
essential that you have a portfolio that
will showcase your work now a good
portfolio will include examples of the
kind of research that you have done how
did you convert those Research into
recommendations how did you what
recommendations did you identify now how
does this look in terms of you know
storyboarding in terms of how the layout
of that product or service changed so um
a portfolio is very important for a
career as a design professional so in
short this is what a sample job
description looks like and I have broken
it down to explain to you why all of
this comes apart of job description are
there any questions that I should be
taking right now
uh I think we are getting a lot of
questions in the Q a box uh we'll be
taking it sometime uh folks who are
asking questions on chat I'm so sorry
I'll miss it because we're getting a lot
of messages that so please go and put it
in the Q a box we'll take it in some
time meanwhile I'm going to talk about
the career paths in UI ux uh so
Professor Preeti what are the career
paths people can follow in UI ux uh I'm
sure it is not only limited to being a
US designer
uh yeah it's not just uh uh limited to
that so there are
um you know these um
the titles that come with job
descriptions could also vary depending
on the industry
um or the organization that you are in
startups typically expect you to be able
to do a little bit of everything
um uh bigger organizations who have more
resources who have more budget typically
have a very specific uh rules so uh the
most common uh designations that you
will come across
um because uh you know the field of ux
and UI it offers a very wide range of uh
career paths and opportunities so for
instance if you take the job description
of a ux designer they will really be
focusing on the overall user experience
of a product and then they will ensure
that you know intuitive it's user
friendly you will be conducting user
research user personas when you look at
the uh kind of things that a UI designer
is expected to do they will mostly focus
on the visual layout of a product what
kind of color schemes should we be
including
what should the typography of that of
the screen layout look like which means
what kind of lettering in short you
should be using what kind of font so all
of that comes under the typographical
elements then there's also the element
of iconography what kind of icons should
you be designing to get users to click
so for instance if there is a chat box
so how will that chat box look like
right uh visually how will you represent
that all of that comes under iconography
then there are various other
designations such as you know
um interaction design so um what will
the interaction flow between the user
and the product look like so for
instance you know take things such as
sometimes then you are transitioning
from one screen to another
um uh for that screen to load sometimes
you will have an animation uh to uh let
you know that please wait the screen is
loading so how will you design that
animation
um uh what are the micro interactions uh
how will they look like in the usage of
the product
um then uh user researcher for instance
is going to be spending a lot of time in
the field you will be gathering insights
into user Behavior you will be an expert
in conducting interviews designing
surveys
um helping your product you know when
you go to the customer and do usability
testing what kind of Protocols are you
going to draw what kind of scenarios
will you give people
um to help test the product then um you
know a developers role like I said will
be very heavy on front-end coding and
implementing the design so here is where
your programming and coding skills
um uh will take place or which will have
a greater importance so as a developer
you will ensure that you you know
whatever design requirements are coming
from the design team is accurately
translated in the way that you're coding
and programming uh the interface so that
the front-end experience of the user
becomes seamless so these are
essentially uh what each of these uh
designations mean but like I said
um a lot of this also depends on what
kind of organization you're working at
startups because they are smaller
because they have lesser budgets they
would typically expect you to you know a
little bit know and work on a little bit
of everything whereas you know if you
take a company like Google or Samsung
they will have very specific skill sets
for each of these your your job
responsibilities are more clearly can be
more clearly delineated
it explains it well uh I just had a
question like but there's always a
dilemma right where do you get started
um where do you get started in the
Sensei a formal
um entry into the field uh typically
takes
um the form of uh have you been through
a structured program for it and
um uh you know you could either opt to
go to a design school which would
typically be a two-year or a four year
full-time program there are certificate
courses such as the webinar for this one
that you're attending which you can do
online so
um where do you start you have various
entry points depending on what your
professional needs are what are your
budget what kind of budget do you have
available what kind of time do you have
available so there is no one straight
answer to this for instance some of you
may be mid-career professionals who are
looking to understanding more about
design you obviously will not have the
time to go back to a design school and
spend two years or four years full time
getting a degree or probably looking at
something that you can do on the site
but which will also help you
learn the skills required for this kind
of profession so it really depends where
in your professional and career Journey
you are placed what your goals and
objectives are are you looking at
understanding UI ux to complement your
existing job role or are you looking to
understanding UI ux to switch to this
particular career path so uh I think
depending it it really depends on what
what your needs and requirements are and
where you currently are placed in your
uh in your career and what kind of
budgetary and time constraints do you
have based on all of this then we can
make a decision about where you should
be beginning from
awesome I hope that answers your
question I think we're getting a few
questions on the chart and Q a boxes
we'll be taking those uh meanwhile uh I
would love to know basically what is
exactly stopping you from becoming a UAV
expert
so you can see a quick hole on your
screen right now it's very easy all you
need to do is uh basically select an
answer you can see uh select multiple
answers as well so first one is I can't
find a fully comprehensive program uh to
take with and the second one is I
wouldn't get the Practical exposure I
need to become a uax designer and the
third one is I find it difficult to
learn from pre-recorded videos and the
fourth one is my work schedule won't
allow me enough time for learning so uh
I can see the polls moving I'll give it
like 15 seconds more uh folks who have
not voted it uh I can see the polls
moving towards I wouldn't get uh we
wouldn't get the Practical exposure and
uh okay it's between my work schedule
wouldn't allow let's see let's give it
like 10 seconds more folks who have not
voted if you're joined from your laptop
or mobile you can see a poll on your
screen right now uh where it asks you
like what exactly is stopping you from
taking this UI work certification
we have talked about the skills we have
talked about the career paths uh so what
exactly is stopping you from taking the
UI red certification we would love to
know so we can help you out better so uh
folks who have not voted yet please go
and board I'll be closing the poll in 10
seconds the polls are still moving by
the way so we are still uh in between
what exactly is the most uh you know
obvious problem for
basically taking up this course
okay I'll be closing the poll in five
seconds
so few of the folks have not voted it's
a very quick poll you can see on your
screen you can just select that option
and submit it so I'll be closing the
poll in five seconds so five
four
three
two
one okay let me end the call now so
let's see what is the biggest concern
Professor Priti uh for folks here so let
me just share the results
uh we can see the uh we can see it's
basically a tie between surprisingly
between the first second and fourth
option basically the first one being the
icon finder fully comprehensive
curriculum uh the second one also being
a tie I wouldn't get the Practical
exposure I need to become a ux designer
and the fourth one my work schedule
won't allow me enough time for Learning
and we've brought in a few votes in I
find it difficult to learn from
pre-recorded videos uh so I'll just stop
sharing the poll
and we'll be talking about the UI ux
certification by triple it Bangalore uh
so the program for triple it Bangalore
is an industry learning path and uh we
can see that the program offers a
comprehensive curriculum with an
industry aligned learning path and also
uh we have integrated case studies
Hands-On project experience uh for
practical experience we have online live
virtual classroom with peer and interest
interaction and also we have a flexible
to fit lifestyle uh to your schedule and
the program duration I think someone has
asked like the program duration is of
five months
and uh it will be of 10 to 15 hours a
week uh that is all you will need for
completing the certification and
becoming a uivx design expert uh but I
do have a question uh like Professor
Priti what happens in the live Learning
Classroom like do they experience only a
live lecture or does it offer more than
that can you tell us something about it
right so I conduct master classes uh
which uh which are what live learning
sessions are also called so I have with
my along with my colleagues uh uh we
conduct uh master classes for the
students so in these master classes we
tend to talk about topics that are not a
part of uh
um you know the formal uh curriculum
which is quite tightly structured to
help you keep on a path and to help you
complete so we bring in complementary
perspectives to what are part of your
syllabus but are not included in the
syllabus and uh because they are live
sessions they are more interactive and
uh you know you can have a very engaging
uh question answer session
um uh with the instructors I personally
um enjoy doing the live sessions for
this program a fair bit because
um it allows me to also talk about the
kind of projects I'm working on it
allows me to expand and go beyond the
things that I've said in the syllabus
and uh I've observed that uh you know
there is a lot of Engagement from the
students and the kind of questions they
ask
um really add because it's often very
thought provoking and also gives me food
for thought you know what is it that
students are thinking
um so uh this is what you can typically
expect in a live learning uh session and
it is not just going to be me uh later
on in in the presentation you will see
that there are other people other
faculty members also involved in the
program so you will get to know who this
who these instructors are to
awesome thank you so much for the answer
also like uh it's five months of
duration and 10 to 15 hours per week
like enough for uh basically completing
the certification
well uh that really depends on the kind
of commitment that students have if you
are following the Arc of the program
then I I would imagine that it would be
sufficient to be able to finish it by
then
okay because as with anything you need
your you know you can't just sign on and
you know you can't be like oh I'll watch
the recorded videos later if you're
going to procrastinate then it will
affect the uh time that you take to
understand the topics and
um how much time are you spending on
assignments and to complete assignments
so it really depends on the kind of
commitment you are bringing to a program
and that is true of anything not just
this particular certificate too agree
agree agree I think people need to put
an effort right in order to achieve that
level of productivity as well right not
just recorded videos uh so uh yeah
basically what exactly you will be
getting uh from this program as well uh
so you'll be getting a triple ITV UI WX
program certificate as you can see on
the screen right now and also you will
be getting Hands-On learning experience
with industry based projects including a
Capstone one which we are going to talk
about it uh also live master classes
will be delivered by top design experts
from Adobe Amazon and Microsoft and uh
you'll be getting masterclassic with
triple IIT Bangalore faculty as well
which Professor vidhi mentioned and also
civilian jobs career service as well
uh we will be talking about the triple
it uh Bangalore Advantage as well
Professor pretty can you tell us what
advantage folks are getting by taking
the certificate from triple it Bangalore
itself
right so triple it Bangalore is uh uh uh
research
um uh institution that uh is a
recognized name in the delivery of
engineering education now along with
engineering we also have a course called
the Masters in Digital Society program
and this particular course was really to
bring a introduce students to the
societal aspects of technology and
um therefore the vision of triple it
Bangalore was really how do we
contribute to the information technology
world and because we are increasingly
living in a digital world today how can
we enhance the education research
entrepreneurship and Innovation
prospects to strengthen our program
um so the triple ITB Advantage is that
you know this is a very recognized and
an established name in engineering and
the social sciences and
um we also The Institute has has a lot
of very strong industry collaborations
however as I mentioned right at the
beginning when I was introducing myself
academic producing academic scholarship
is also a very important part of being a
faculty member at triple it Bangalore so
um therefore all faculty members
associated with The Institute are
constantly engaged in generating
original scholarship and therefore the
strength of this particular Institute is
that you get both practical learning as
well as insights from the academic
uh that's really amazing thank you so
much for the advantage part also uh
we'll be taking you through the
eligibility and prerequisite as well uh
so both for aspiring new designers and
current designers wishing to upscale uh
so all you need to do is you need to
have a bachelor degree with 50 page or
higher marks and a diploma with 50 marks
and a minimum of one year of experience
so uh so this is something you will be
needed but uh I wanted to ask Professor
preethi that have you seen student
succeed coming from a non-designing
background
I mean yes because the point of taking a
program like this is to learn design
isn't it so you will not have a design
background before you have either worked
in it or you have learned it
so um you don't necessarily need to have
prior exposure in design or in coding or
programming programs like this are
designed to help you acquire those
skills awesome awesome uh so I think I
would like to know like uh how many
years of experience do your folks have
uh let's get to know each other better
so I would love to know how many years
of experience do your folks have so I
can see the pores moving you will see a
poll on your screen uh all you need to
do is if you need to select one option
and submit it as per the most suitable
option which is to you as per your
experience so if you're currently
studying you can select the first option
if you have zero to three years of
experience you can select the second one
if you have three to five years of
experience you're a mid-level
professional you can select the third
one and the fourth one if you have more
than five years of experience I can see
the pores moving uh we've gotten a
really interactive audience here they're
pretty quick I must say on polls and
also pretty quick in the Q a box we have
gotten a lot of questions on the Q a box
so we'll be taking that in sometime
please don't worry about that so yeah
I'll be closing the poll in uh 10
seconds so I would like only few of the
folks who are left who have not voted
yet to uh just to vote like how many
years of experience do you have so I
will understand better you know uh where
you're coming from and the questions you
have as well
so I'll be closing the poll in 10
seconds
I can see the pores moving still
okay
we actually are getting 100
participation by the way Professor
that's pretty that's pretty great that's
fun
okay I'll be closing the poll in five
seconds
five
four
three
two one okay let me end the poll and
share the results
uh thank you for voting everyone uh so
we can see uh almost half of the folks
are currently studying and uh for some
uh 30 of the folks are having zero to
three years of experience that's great
and I can see few of the folks have more
than five years of experience and very
few of them have mid-level professional
three to five years of experience
awesome
uh now we'll be talking about how this
program basically prepares you uh so
we'll be talking about uh how exactly
this program prepares you and Professor
tweeting can you take us through the
skills like step by step
so essentially when you enroll for the
program you will first have an
orientation session then the first
module that you will be exposed to will
be on user experience Design This will
be followed by a module on user
interface and design principles you will
then move on to learning about
prototyping and styling your mock-ups
and products and this will then lead to
user research and testing because once
you have your prototypes ready you have
to test it with the users and all of
this will then culminate in a Capstone
project and we'll talk to you more about
what a Capstone project involves now
complementing this particular curriculum
like I said you will be having master
classes or live sessions
um with both faculty from triple it
Bangalore as well as industry
professionals you will also as part of
the curriculum be involved in several
practical activities such as an example
is you you know build a real world
website from scratch and you will also
be exposed to
um several Concepts that are that
contribute to what we call as design
thinking so in short this is how the
program will help you build your uh UI
ux design skills
Russia you are on mute you're not
audible okay okay so sorry so I was
saying that uh thank you so much for
explaining that and just to let you know
the electives which you see here uh will
be a part of the program uh and they are
optional so we will not be charging you
anything extra for that it is up to you
if you want to take those up uh so yeah
now moving on uh to the tools uh we
still get to master in this UI ux uh
design program uh I can see like uh you
know a few tools on the screen Sigma
Envision sketch and uh I'm pretty sure
many more tools are covered in this
program can you tell us about that a
little about that yeah so uh the thing
about tools is that uh you know you have
to tools keep changing like I said
design is a very Dynamic uh industry and
an environment so a few years ago
balsamic was the most popular tool and
that was the industry standard today it
is stigma that is the industry standard
so you should not stress too much about
oh I know balsamic and I will not be
able to um transition into figma because
if you know the broad principles and
what these tools help you do you will be
able to work across these domains of
course you will have to spend a little
time learning but it is not at all
difficult and to help you Orient to all
of these tools we uh I think the
certificate program does not teach you
any one tool but it teaches you various
tools so you will be exposed to figma of
course but you will also be exposed to
balsamic to sketch to Envision so you
can expect all of these tools to be a
part of your learning that is part of
the certificate program
awesome uh let's move on to the next one
uh I think we have talked about the
Capstone project uh but how does exactly
our caption project uh you know help us
in finding our job in uifx uh while in
our jobs is post the proposed the
certification and uh does is it a plus
like having it on your CV the professor
printing right so a Capstone project is
essentially what happens at the end of a
program you will find the term Capstone
used both in certificate programs such
as simply learn and even you know a
master's program a good Masters Pro
program in design will generally have
students working on a Capstone project
now it is called a Capstone because it
is capping the end of your uh program so
everything that you have learned in the
duration of the program can be expressed
through your project this becomes even
more important in the design field
because you need a portfolio so you
really need to show concrete examples of
the kind of work that you have done and
what is it that you have learned it is
not enough for you to sit across
somebody and explain to them verbally
you have to give them examples of the
work that you have done right so um you
can think of it or you can think of a
Capstone project as something that is a
culmination of everything that you have
um learned and the demonstration you are
demonstrating how you have applied those
learnings applied those Knowledge and
Skills in the form of a project that you
do at the end so this certificate
program also has a Capstone project so
um it will require you to apply uh
everything that you have learned in your
courses to a real world project and
um uh caption projects typically involve
original research primary data
collection that you will do and a
display of the kind of creative work
like for instance so if you've created a
screen layout what are the kind of icons
for instance that you have designed and
how are you designing the information
architect and the user flow journey of
your users Capstone projects are highly
valued because they showcase the
independent work that a student has done
so this is your own work however you
don't work alone you do receive
supervision
advising and guidance from your mentors
who are going to be taking you through
this program
um and um a Capstone project also
showcases how well you are able to
present your work so your communication
you also get a chance to improve learn
and showcase your communication skills
and uh they are like I said extremely
important because they're very core to
the portfolio that you are going to
um uh design as part of your resume to
let potential employers know
um what are your capabilities and how
well you are able to execute and what
have you learned
um as a aspiring design professional why
should you be higher auditioned
also uh we'll be talking about the
learning environment quickly uh before
we move on to the Q a section as well I
can see folks are asking about the
programs here are a lot more details uh
Professor can you tell us a little about
the learning environment what exactly
happens there so um this is obviously
going to be virtual so
um I assume you are going to be having
the tools to manage your curriculum uh
simply learn will probably be using a
learning platform and you will be
getting login credentials you will be uh
there will be demonstrations of tests
that you will probably have to take to
uh you know assess your learnings
through the program
um there will be a Capstone project that
I just explained that will uh
showcase everything that you have
learned over uh the five months that
you're going to be as part of a program
you will have the tools to track your
own progress and
certificates that will be given to you
showcasing what particular aspects of
the program you have completed and there
will be various support tools to help
you accomplish this
so uh so we also have like global
leaders as programming devices uh so we
have Professor V sridha which Professor
baby talked about that you know the
other folks also will be digging it up
uh so these are a few other folks we can
see so uh Professor B sridhar uh is
faculty in charge uh and uh we can see
Professor uh Amit prakash who's actually
an associate professor uh and has
co-founded two startups memory
technology and vision and power we have
Professor Titi with us who all already
have given you an introduction uh and
also we have uh basically we have been
working with industry design experts as
well as Internet instructors which also
we have mentioned before so we have
vishak Anand who actually is a senior ux
designer at Amazon we have arushi Tandon
who is a senior ux designer in Microsoft
uh we have Chetan yadav who is a U.S
designer Adobe
we'll be talking about learner outcomes
here uh so initially when mentioned that
simple and also helps with the job
assist service which helps you search uh
in your job search or you know uh
process which basically what you get out
of it is you'll get free access to
expert webinars and also you'll get to
work on real world projects across
Industries and also you'll be getting
job assist Services which we have in
association with IM jobs uh in this uh
geography Services by IM job you'll be
getting access to the job portal and uh
you will be getting a resume review and
rewrite Service as well uh while you're
preparing for interviews uh you'll be
getting one-on-one interview Service as
well
uh we also have such expert webinars
with industry leaders you know
throughout the month you can check it
out on simply learn uh section FRS
section and uh would love to know
basically are you interested in
enrolling in this program uh of UI
you've accepted Advanced certification
by triple it Bangalore you can see a
quick poll on your screen right now uh
you can see an option yes here and uh
you can just vote for your answer here
on your screen uh so this would help us
to know that uh what your interest is
exactly so I would love to know if
you're interested in enrolling the
program you can see a quick pull on your
screen I can see the polls moving right
now and I can see a lot of folks who are
interested in this program that's good
to know that's good to know so yeah
so I'll be giving 10 seconds more for a
few of the folks who have not voted yet
so would you like to enroll in this
program of triple it bangalore's
Advanced certification in UI of x uh you
can choose the option yes uh on your
screen right now if you are still
thinking about it you can choose the
option yes uh you know we're basically
making sure you get a full uh
walkthrough of the program even after
this uh from a learning consultant from
Simply done so yeah I'll be closing the
poll in 10 seconds so if you're the
folks who have not voted they can go and
vote on the quick poll on their screen
uh would you like to enroll in this
program uh of triple it bangalore's
Advanced certification in urdx
see I can see the polls still moving uh
I can see a lot of folks interested in
the program that's great so I'll be
closing the poll in five seconds
so five four three two one
thank you so much folks who have uh
voted we have gotten a very interactive
audience here and you can see that a 78
of the folks are interested in enrolling
the program yeah it is it is an amazing
program to enroll in and I'm sure okay
uh we'll be taking you through the
enrollment steps here as well so you can
see on your screen right now that you
can basically easiest three simple steps
are there you can just submit an
application uh to us and ask us at
simplylearn.net and uh you'll be your
application will be growing in review
and uh once the application is reviewed
you'll be getting an admission
through uh simply learns learning
consultant uh the program is something a
lot of folks have asked about so the
program fee for this course is one lakh
6200 and uh in you need uh financing
options that is also available for as
low as 3614 per month and for the cohort
which is starting currently we have an
induction session on 18 August and the
classes will be starting on 21st of
October so you can see that and also uh
if you have any more questions about the
course uh you can always reach out to us
at ask us at centrion.net
so how soon do you plan to enroll in
this program so I would really recommend
for folks who have answered yes and no I
can understand that you're still
thinking about it for me for folks who
have answered yes you can just see a
quick poll on your screen basically how
soon do you plan to enroll so do you
plan to enroll immediately you can
choose the first option if you plan to
enroll within three months you can
choose the second one if you plan to
enroll within six months you can choose
the third one if you plan to enroll
within six months from now you can
choose that one for folks who have
responded Yes I would recommend uh to go
and vote for this uh poll this will help
us understand when exactly are you
planning to enroll so if you plan to
enroll immediately you can choose this
one as you can see the covert starts
from October 21st so anyways if they
will have time for that so yeah I'll be
closing the poll in 10 seconds
I can see folks are still voting in
the polls are still moving so whatever
you're comfortable with like when do you
plan to enroll so immediately if you
want to enroll you can choose the first
option on your screen it's a very quick
poll you can just select one option and
submit it
still thinking about it I would suggest
to select an option of within three
months uh so that's like an enough time
you know uh to basically go through the
course as well and uh a good call from
learning consultant from Sabrina will
also give you a good idea about the
course you know when exactly you would
want to take up
so yeah I can see the post still moving
so what I will do is I'll give like 10
seconds more and we'll be closing the
poll in 10 seconds
for few folks who have not voted I would
suggest like go and select an option
which is more suitable to you how soon
do you plan to enroll
if immediately it is your answer that is
the first
second one
okay I'll be using the poll in five
seconds
so five
four
three
to
1 okay let me end the polar
okay I can see uh like I have the folks
uh want to join within three months
that's great uh I can see uh less than
half want to uh join immediately as well
I can see some folks are still thinking
on it they want to join uh within six
months or six months from now so that's
great
uh now we'll be going to the Q a uh
section uh so I know you have been
waiting for this and we have so many
questions in the queue in a box so it
will try to take as much as possible uh
so Dr pretty if I think we can start
with uh
okay I think uh banutto has asked like
uh as I am a fresher is it good to learn
UI of X I think this is something you
have answered already uh
um okay let me just go through the
questions meanwhile folks in case you're
putting down your questions on chat I
might miss it so please go and put it on
in the Q a box
okay uh so I can see one question I am
currently a PhD student in education I
have a master's degree in educational
technology is it possible to get a job
as a ux researcher with no experience in
Tech Professor pretty
well it depends on what what your
definition of tech is by Tech are you
referring to engineering skills here
um it's not quite clear like I mentioned
through the presentation uh you don't
really need coding and programming
skills to make a career in design so I'm
a bit confused about how you are
defining technology if you're still
around and attending please uh type in
what your definition of tech is so that
I can better clarify this point
yeah please do that on chart and we'll
take that up or you can do that in the Q
a box as well I can see what one person
has asked like hello ma'am I'm a graphic
designer and have five ways of
experience uh ma'am as a designer should
I update myself as a UI Works designer
I'm uh I like creating and designing so
which is good UI or ux
um it really depends I mean if you um if
you enjoy desire if you enjoy like
drawing in the creative aspect I could
imagine that uh the UI component which
is more which deals with the more visual
aspects of the job may be something that
you're more suited to because uh you
know as I mentioned through my
presentation uh UI professionals
typically deal with things uh that have
to do with the visual layout including
iconography color schemes typographical
decisions
um so if those are the skills that you
feel you are stronger at then it may
well be that you could be better at it
some people are better at both some
people lean towards
um you know either UI or ux
um
so whatever helps you make the best use
of your capabilities as well as interest
because it is very important that we
also like what we work you know the kind
of work that we do it is important for
us to like it otherwise it's just going
to be very boring and you will even if
you're earning good money if you don't
like your job then it is not going to be
pleasurable
I hope that answers your question uh so
a professor Priti we have been getting a
lot of these questions related to uh do
we require coding in order to learn
uivex
no and as we mentioned a program like
this we will equip you with basic coding
and programming skills it will not uh
hurt you although it's also not super
essential uh you can have a design
career without uh necessarily knowing it
but your portfolio and your resume
becomes stronger if you also have an
acquaintance with knowing it but
um coding and programming becomes
important if you want the developer role
right it is more important for developer
roles you can't become a developer
without knowing programming and coding
but you can become a design Professional
but it will help you if you know the
rudimentary basics of programming in
Google
I hope that answers your question uh we
have one question from Ajit I can see
aha hiya Majid I'm working in non-voice
process for more than two years uh then
I researched about UI ux can you give me
an idea of how to enter as a fresher in
UI of x uh basically designing what
should I learn to get started with
Basics right I think I already addressed
a question like this in the presentation
because I think somebody else had also
asked how do I start so as I mentioned
where you start from and how you start
from really depends on where you are in
your career right now there are various
different ways to start uh as freshers
of course you know you can attend a
design school as a mid-career
professional or as an early career
professional
um if you don't want to go back to
school and spend uh two to four years
full time as a student or if you don't
have the kind of money to pay those fees
then certificate programs like these
allow you both uh practical as well as
theoretical orientation to the design
field and because you will have
assignments and because you will have a
Capstone project you will also be able
to show very concrete examples of the
work that you have done because you need
to build a portfolio so building a
portfolio is typically where you should
be beginning with and how you go about
building a portfolio is by doing
projects
I hope that answers your question uh one
more question but a little different
like I can see from shanu I am an art
director uh in one of the repeated
advertising agencies uh but my English
communication is not good can I become a
U.S designer
um I I would imagine that you can there
is nothing stopping you from becoming a
design professional that said there is
also nothing stopping you from improving
your uh communication skills in English
um as long as you are a good team player
uh because teamwork is important
collaboration is important as long as
you're able to do that
um I think you should be fine
awesome we are getting our one
interesting question on uh chat here
that uh Preeti ma'am who is in
inspirations
who is my inspiration there are a range
of people at different stages in my
career who have acted uh as
inspirational uh figures for me I'm
primarily a researcher uh and therefore
any piece of good writing is very
inspiring
uh I hope that answers your question
that's really amazing I'm pretty sure we
have like different different
Inspirations for different uh things in
life okay I think uh we have answered
the question about coding it does not
require coding and they will teach you a
little bit of coding as well so you
don't have to worry about that
okay I can see one question from Shiva
uh so ma'am I am shivara thank you for
explaining your nicely I think you
answer one of his questions during the
session uh I have one more doubt I will
be interested in front of development
and also very much interested in ui's
designing uh is this both domains
require same work or different I've seen
a video in the internet that a person
who made a design product in figma and
he converted that Sigma link to sandton
core with just few clicks I'm confused
how come it is possible to convert the
figma design to front-end code please
help me now yeah so that is a feature of
Sigma however is that front front-end
code going to be directly implemented in
a live project I'm doubtful that Sigma
just allows you to do to be able to show
and demo an interaction that doesn't
mean that that entire code is going to
be piecemeal copy pasted into your final
product you do need programming and
coding skills to be able to do that we
use that particular feature of figma
that you're referring to my students
generally use it to just show how the
how the interaction flow of the
Prototype would look like
uh I hope that answers your question and
I can see one question uh that I've been
looking through JD's for interior design
jobs most of which required uavs can you
please give us a brief on how URLs helps
in interior designing
um I don't know how it would help in
interior designing all I will say is
that to be a good design professional
you need to have a good sense of
Aesthetics
um you need to uh you know be very good
at being able to talk to your client
understanding the needs and requirements
and then converting it into suggestions
that you will then execute with the help
of you know a range of other
professionals such as Carpenters
painters
um uh plumbers electricians so
um I guess you could learn the skills of
gathering user requirements and then
applying it to the field of interior
design
but UI UI is generally to do with
digital interfaces
um so in fact if you're a good interior
designer because you have to design
digital interfaces maybe that will be
more helpful for you yeah because we are
not dealing with buildings in UI ux we
are or in you know in the very limited
way that we understand UI ux here we are
mainly dealing with digital interfaces
it is in the digital world that the
design professionals generally come with
the tag of user interface and user
experience
I hope that answers your question uh I
can say apurva has asked us quick
question that difference between a
product designer and a UI ux designer
difference between a product design and
a UI ux designer so a product designer
would probably have like I mentioned
earlier depending on the organization
that you're working for these
designations could mean different things
in different places but if you're
talking about a product designer
um which is coming mainly from the
industrial design perspective it could
mean for instance you know you could be
hired maybe at Ikea and they might ask
you like you know how do I build this
chair so that is typically what a
product designer would do
um uh in a non-digital domain so product
designers generally come from the
industrial engineering ergonomics uh
background where they're designing
Furniture where they are designing uh
um uh you know electronic appliances so
that is typically the role of a product
designer
um whereas a UI ux designer like I said
is mainly to mainly people working on
digital interfaces there are product
managers who will like I mentioned
oversee the entire
uh process you know integrating both
business needs as well as user needs so
those are typically known as product
managers but product designers are deal
with non-digital interface products
Furnitures electronic appliances
things like that
I hope that answers your question uh I
can see one interesting question on chat
here by tanvir any motivation or
suggestions for me as I'm planning to
take a course I take a break and focus
fully on this course uh please help
all the best to you and I hope you do
well I mean uh I don't have any
suggestions you would know your uh
scenario the best you would know your
situation the best so without knowing
anything about you it it will be very
difficult to give suggestions or
motivations because they're very
particular to the kind of contexts we
come from so it really depends on what
our uh
constraints are what are contexts are
what are aspirations are
so depending on all of that we will be
able to motivate and give you
suggestions
I hope that answers your question and
all the best for taking up the course
while you're taking a break I can see
one interesting question from here uh
ma'am I am a business analyst in
development of web and mobile
applications uh do you think that the
course will help me in identifying
analyzing the requirements better
yeah I would imagine because you are not
directly involved in uh in the design
process in your job you're a business
analyst which means that you're mainly
dealing with data with numbers uh so
this course will be new for you in that
sense so if you if you are aspiring to
be a design professional then this
course could act as a good entry point
for you into the design mode
I hope that answers your question uh I
can see one more question uh I have
eight years of experience as a graph
designer and did six months uox design
online course as I want to switch my
career but not getting jobs in uav's job
as a fresher so like I think that is
something about the course we would have
to know about that for that you can ask
us at uh basically ask us at selena.net
uh I think
I think one question we have hi ma'am
I'm yes can you please tell me how to be
creative and confident in a field like
UI of x
well how do you be creative and
confident confidence comes to us when we
successfully execute projects right so
you start with smaller projects you
start with smaller assignments you do
them you get feedback from your mentors
from your instructors they will let you
know what you have done well what you
have not done well
um you integrate those learnings in the
next project that you do and you again
receive feedback and it is through this
process that our confidence builds right
so you actually have to do something to
be able to become confident uh unless
you do that you are not going to gain
the experience so this is what I would
suggest
uh thank you for your answer Professor
PT I hope that answers your question I
think I've gotten one question about are
there any upcoming patches post August
patch if yes then uh so yeah we have a
batch starting in October uh so you can
check out about that and uh in the
civilian website or also like Melissa
said ask us at similar.net uh also uh if
you have already chosen the option you
know within three months if you're
looking for so you don't worry about it
it'll be contacting you for that
all the questions here uh so uh I think
let's move on to the poll
so uh for folks who have chosen that
they are interested in enrolling in the
program and also like you know within
six months three months immediately you
can see a very quick poll on your screen
uh basically do you need assistant to
enroll I'm pretty sure you want to know
more of your program and uh we will make
sure that you get a walkthrough of the
program uh you'll be getting a call from
Simply learns learning consultant and
we'll be taking you through the triple
IDs Advanced certification program in UI
of X so I'm pretty sure just go and vote
for yes you definitely need this
assistant to enroll and it's always good
to know right get more help before you
take up the program so I I would suggest
to vote for yes and uh yeah we'll be
getting in touch with you uh for taking
you through the program I'm pretty sure
you have more questions uh you know
about the program
yeah we'll be helping you with that so
you will see a quick poll on your screen
uh all you need to do is Select an
option like if you want assistance to
enroll in this program for folks who
have chosen yes I would highly recommend
yes because yes uh you can definitely
take this system from Simply learns
learning consultant we'll be getting in
touch with you
awesome I can see folks are still voting
in so I'll get give it 15 seconds more
uh so do you need this assistant to
enroll in the program for folks who have
asked questions
you can see a quick poll on your screen
right now uh do you need assistance to
enroll in this program
yeah
we'll be closing the poll in 10 seconds
for a few of the folks who have not
voted it I would suggest to go and take
the assistance for sure so you can vote
for yes if you want the assistance
on your screen it's a very quick poll
okay I'll be closing the poll in five
seconds now
so five
four three two
one
I can see how more than half the folks
need an assistant to enroll in the
program so that's great
so we are towards the end of the session
uh thank you so much folks for joining
I'm sure like you might have a lot more
questions about the program so you can
always mail us at ask us at
simplyleon.net and you so you can also
scan this code in order to uh you know
view the program as well uh Professor
prini thank you for joining us and
taking us to the program and giving us a
detailed overview of the program as well
and thank you for answering a lot of
questions we have gotten a lot of
questions throughout the session and
thank you for taking that time out to
answer the question as well
you're most welcome I wish everybody who
is still with us all the very best
um with the career goals and aspirations
and I hope if you're enrolling for the
program you will learn a lot that will
stand you in good state in your career
so thank you will be ending the program
now thank you for being a great audience
as well thank you thank you so much
folks